and the Bon Jovi stuff is what is really
was the promo leak or whatever oh that
was like a New York pose
yeah like it's not bad for the book no
but listen again this was a long time
ago there's an incident that you're
referring to in 1989 we used to have
these ends of tour high jinks and the
New York Post headline yesterday yes Jon
Bon Jovi's dad threatened to kill
Sebastian Bach there's a nice headline a
great and lovely headline but that
refers to a very specific incident that
happened where I learned if you insult
one Italian mm-hmm the whole [ __ ]
family comes at you I see the father the
brother everybody and the road crew so
why did you insult him or what happened
cuz he whipped [ __ ] he dumped my head
and a vat of ice milk hmm I don't want
to give away the whole book was I smoke
on tour I think the end of tour hide
that [ __ ] we're bands of grease up the
drumsticks I didn't know they do that no
I know well I was on the roll of Pantera
once and I put my mic up to sing and my
mouth starts burn and enjoy what the
[ __ ] and I wipe it up my lives of my eye
ah and they're all laughing and they
doused my mic in Tabasco I smoked would
have helped them but don't can I stage
yeah lights are out and I feel about six
dudes just grabbed me I don't know
what's going on and just dunk my head
and hold me under in a vat of like
freezing cold
I smell as the first song is starting
yeah and I'm supposed to be up there for
the first verse and I'm under the stage
and you know when you jump into ours
to cold you get that vertigo yeah I got
milk all over me but but you gotta read
the rest of it
yeah after